but we're going to begin with a crucial
election day in Georgia you know all
about it campaigning is over for
Democratic senator Rafael Warnock and
Republican Challenger Herschel Walker
now it's up to you the voters in Georgia
around 2 million voters there have
already cast their ballots in this
runoff after neither candidate got 50
percent of the vote back in November the
coal killing is is north of Atlanta
right now where the polls have just
opened up Nicole good morning to you I
saw a speech with Rafael Warnock last
night where he says tell Lottie Dottie
and everybody to get out and vote today
I think that's a good way to end this
campaign so what are you expecting in
terms of turnout because I hear weather
could be an issue
yeah that's right and it's a key message
from both candidates but look the
weather will be a critical factor with
scattered showers expected throughout
the day but it doesn't seem to be
dampening the spirit of Voters or
candidates who are ready for this race
to be decided once and for all
I'm not going to sleep tonight because
before a big game I don't sleep because
I'm ready so I want y'all to get ready
after weeks in overtime it's election
day again in Georgia so let's carry this
thing all the way to the Finish Line the
campaigning so let's go warn out some
doors
canvassing this is
all comes down to this I want you to
vote I'm going to get out and vote vote
vote on their last full day on the trail
income and Democratic senator Rafia
Warnock and Republican Challenger
Herschel Walker brought out a stream of
surrogate two notables who stayed away
the current and former president weighed
in with last minute pitches Trump got
out the vote for Walker on social media
in a cello rally while Mr Biden called
into an Atlanta radio station all the
things that Reverend Warnock has
supported are things that the people of
Georgia care a great deal about roughly
35 000 votes separated both candidates
last month in a campaign punctuated by
controversial headlines and personal
attacks if he can't be serious and
honest about his past Jordans can't
count on him Rebel one I was running a
nasty dishonest campaign
perfect for Washington we get bombarded
with the calls and the commercials
people knocking at your door now like
it's just a lot at this Atlanta area
Diner voters say they're finally ready
to see what today's runoff will serve I
feel like uh things are a toss-up it
could go either way the Democrats have
control already but you know I think
just getting another voice in there
Republican voice so I'm for that
more than 90 million dollars has been
spent in this runoff which is the last
remaining midterm contest in the country
a Warnock win would solidify Democrats
advantage in the Senate while a walker
win would weaken their grip in an evenly
divided chamber Tony
and 2022 is almost over as an election
season anyway Nicole thank you very much